[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000 as always my name is Caleb
Denby and I will be your driver on this
journey
today's a fun day the uh Olympiad just
wrapped up so the Olympiad is always a
ton of fun you get the best players from
every country coming out to compete and
there are a lot of countries and that
means a lot of fun games to to go over
uh so today I wanted to go through some
of those games that I thought we could
learn from from and these games actually
all happened in in the final round uh so
it is now over
um it turns out it Uzbekistan is the
strongest chess country this year they
took home the gold medal in the open
section I believe Ukraine won in the
women's
um so we're going to be looking at at a
few different games here tonight I
actually wanted to start off with this
game uh by Sam Shanklin for the US team
against uh
nare yanan
um for Team India two I believe is India
too India of course was the host this
year and they fielded three different
incredibly strong teams
uh two of which placed in the top five
so very strong teams in India I was
actually looking at um the Juniors
ratings ratings list right before we we
got started tonight nine of the top 20
juniors in the world are either from
India or Uzbekistan
um and so it's no surprise to see that
these two teams are doing quite well at
the Olympiad uh but okay let's jump into
this game uh with Sam shankland with the
white pieces
um if the U.S had uh potentially won
their final match they would have been
in contention for the bronze medal I
believe they would have lost out anyways
on tie breaks with how things worked out
but instead I believe we placed fifth so
just outside of the the podium but still
not not a terrible showing
so but Sam got the job done in this game
it starts with D4 Knight F6 C4
six Knight C3 Bishop B4 and we enter the
classical nimso Indian
so are you guys familiar with with the
nimso Indian in general
no okay so the idea for this opening
there are of course many ideas uh white
with this Knight on C3 is challenging
the center and against the qgd
um white has many options one of which
with this move order is to play league
Exchange
but now after Bishop B4 black is saying
I'm gonna pin your knight uh fighting
you for control over the center so
you're not going to be able to play this
movie Fork
um and then the variations sort of
digress from here sometimes black is
going to capture this Knight double
whites pawns provoking some weaknesses
sometimes white is going to take a
calmer approach something like E3 and
just develop the pieces but in this case
we see Queen to C2 so this is sort of an
odd looking move at first glance the
baby is very simple now we can force
this bishop away and instead of
capturing back on C3 with the pawn
making all those weaknesses White's
gonna be able to take back with the
queen uh preserving the structure so for
example if we play A3 here most likely
black will take and now black will very
often try to Target this queen side I've
shown games like this before where you
go after these Pawn weaknesses but after
Queen sees two we'll see that in this
case uh Narayanan chose D5 we get A3 no
black still takes in this case and we
see Queen takes so white gets to keep
the pawns uh nice nice and clean no
broken structure for white
so what was the downside to White
playing Queen C2 in Queen takes C3 does
anybody know what could possibly be the
downside to doing this
right positionally there is no downside
right we just get to keep our structure
we got the bishop in exchange for the
Knight but of course the the downside is
it costs you a lot of time
so the challenge here with black you've
made a positional concession you've
given up your dark Square Bishop your
good Bishop the bishop that doesn't
operate on the same color as the pawns
uh in exchange all you have is white
Spence a few moves to uh to take your
Bishop off the board so this line is
really going to be about black proving
that these three three Tempe these two
Tempe actually make a difference and so
black needs to play very actively here
or else you're just going to be
positionally worse
so part of that is going to involve
trying to make white waste even more
time so here black plays this move B6
so this move should probably strike you
as a little bit
um odd so in general by far the the main
move here is is going to be uh castles I
believe
and you can also try to play actively
with something like C5 in a lot of cases
but you want to Castle the king and then
start coming after white on on the queen
side but we'll see that naryana has a
very interesting idea so let's see what
his idea was first and then we'll we'll
come back to the normal stuff
so here white plays this move Knight F3
this makes a lot of sense black is
intending to open the center and
challenge the the d-pawn very early on
so it's nice to defend this pawn and now
black is going to take on C4
and this is part of the idea for for
black now if white takes too long to
recapture this pun something like E3
you're going to see this bishop gets
hemmed in
and uh black might actually be able to
hold on to this Pawn let me check it's
been a while since I've looked at this
kind of thing but I believe we can just
play this move
um okay maybe we don't want to go B5
looks like Knight B to D7 is is the
simplest
um but much more and more common is to
just take this Pawn back and now we can
again Force white to waste a little bit
of time with Bishop A6 Queen A4 check
and now Queen to descendant so
interestingly black has decided to delay
castling in this line this is nariana's
big idea and so now after Queen to C2 uh
black still isn't going to Castle and
goes Queen to C6
and Sam here simply captures and then uh
and then the game continues so I want to
compare this position with what happens
when black plays the main line which is
castles so we're going to see the game
go down very similar uh into very
similar territory we see takes takes and
now B6 still is the main idea
uh and here you get this interesting
moment where it's White's turn right
compared to B6 in this position
where
um
okay so B6 Knight F3 DC4 Queen C4 here
it is Black's turn and black goes ahead
with the plan Bishop A6 versus this
position
um where after B6 it's white to move and
black is already Castle
so rather than uh Play Bishop A6
basically black has has castled in that
position and this gives white a Tempo uh
so what neuronion uh sorry naryana is
saying is that
uh White's Tempo here is is useful for
white white would love to play Bishop G5
which is the main line
and now after Bishop A6 Queen A4 we're
gonna get all the same things Queen to
C2
um but now if we go to Queen to C6 you
know there's already pressure on this
Knight
so what naryanan is saying is that here
we get the same position
um but you don't have Bishop G5 in yet
and I was able to play more actively
with with Queen to C6 now this is all
well and good but it turns out it's it's
just simply a bad idea
um I think that's all there is to it
it's just not not a great idea here for
black
so what was wrong with with Black's
thinking uh well
it turns out there's a more useful
Square for this bishop than than on G5
so Ariana did all this move order
trickery to try and uh get Sam into a
position where you know black has some
small Improvement right we haven't
committed our King to castling but it
turns out this king is going to Castle
anyways we're going to be owing this
tempo for a while and in return White
NOW gets to keep an option with this
bishop on C1 we are no longer committed
to putting this bishop on G5 and that's
why Sam plays Bishop to F4 here
and after this move black is is already
in in quite a bit of trouble so that was
pretty technical stuff in the nimso
Indian
um the point I was trying to make is
that sometimes
as is the case here
um it's better just to play simple moves
that you know are good that you know are
necessary for your permission position
like castling because while it might
seem counter-intuitive to give your
opponent options uh right no Bishop A6
doesn't really give our opponent a
choice we're playing a very forcing line
gives our opponent all kinds of choices
um but in the opening especially uh
every choice you make is is going to be
somewhat committal and so here we're
forcing white to decide right now do you
want to come to G5 or do you want to
come to F4 and the black has remained
flexible with his pieces and can treat
each line differently versus what
happened in the game
which now
um we've committed all of our pieces as
black and so we're not as flexible we're
not able to deal with White's different
choices
um as easily here and in fact Bishop F4
creates a lot of problems the black is
just not able to solve
um so one more side note so in this main
line if you go Bishop F4 right away
um then we're gonna go Bishop A6 and now
Queen takes C7 results in this line
where we get to sacrifice a pawn and
white can very seriously fall into
trouble quite quickly and this line has
been seen to be totally fine for black
but you'll notice you know we still have
this Knight on C6 we still have Queens
on the board and that's what makes this
line word for black so this is the the
option that black no longer has in the
line in the game right Queens have
already been taken off the board there's
no way we can just sacrifice this pawn
and have activity here right but just
too much has been traded we've committed
this Knight here we're not castled yet
our Rooks aren't coming into the game
um so blackenstead has to play Knight to
D5
okay all of that out of the way let's
see how Sam handles this position uh he
plays Bishop to G3 which makes sense we
want to keep this bishop it applies a
lot of pressure
now black plays Knight C to E7
and we go Rook to C1 and this is simply
the reason why this position is good for
white black has not used the extra time
to uh solve his problem with the C7 pawn
and so instead white just has a very
active dark Square Bishop in exchange
for nothing so once again the point of
this line white spends time to take off
your bishop and preserve his structure
and black needs to do something with
that time or else white will just
strictly be better so that's the case
here
uh black tried Knight to F5 same goes
with E3 and now there are other options
for for white you can even go E4 right
away but I think what Sam did is
perfectly reasonable we get ripped to C8
King to E2
now F6 and Sam does go with E4 here so
takes takes
forces this Knight back and now Sam goes
G4
I'll play a couple more moves castles
Rook C2 H6 rook hc1 and C6
so so far everything Sam has done has
been very very natural right he took
space in the center
um recaptured the bishop and then
doubled his Rooks to Target this this
week's C Pawn
um but what I really want to talk about
with this game now is what Sam does
following this so we played all the
normal looking moves uh we know our
opponent has a weakness but now the
question is how do we continue to press
the position to pressure the position so
to start with Sam plays B4 which makes a
ton of sense we want to lock down this
Square
and now naryana plays Rook to A8 so this
is the first moment I want to pause and
ask you guys to take a moment and think
uh what should we do here with whites
and what is what is black trying to do
so long term what are we trying to do in
short term what's happening right now
any thoughts
yeah what do you think uh I don't know
about long term but immediately I
I consider playing D5 just to
hope to open NSC file
yeah so it's it's worthwhile to look at
all the pawn breaks basically okay I
mean G5 doesn't make much sense but uh
D5 E5 B5 it's worth it to keep these
ideas in in mind
um it turns out just uh concretely here
I don't think any of them are are going
to really work out in our favor right
the C6 Pawn is a weakness so we have to
be really really sure before we're we're
willing to allow black to take like this
and we do get active here
but at the end of the day a pawn is a
pawn and rather than our opponent having
the weakness we're actually going to be
playing the position down down upon now
so D5 doesn't quite work E5 also doesn't
make a ton of sense I think black is
looking for ways to to break out and get
active and we're sort of donating some
some squares to our opponent the central
pandu is really strong as as the duo but
once you push one of them you do give up
some squares and same deal with B5 right
it's upon sacrifice it might not be a
terrible Han sacrifice but we don't want
to give this to our opponent
so let's start with black what on Earth
is this Rook A8 move about
that's the first challenge we need to
solve and then we can talk about long
term
what is Rook A8 about
yeah exactly black is you know not not
happy to sit back and allow us to
pressure this Pawn he's he's trying to
go push this Pawn forward open up the a
file and find his own activity right if
his rook's invade then the C6 Pawn
doesn't matter so much you can just
attack our pawns instead
so our first challenge is to figure out
how we can prevent or at least
discourage the move A5
and that's what this whole game is going
to be about basically from the opening
and Ariana tried this this interesting
idea it didn't really work out and so
Sam has this pretty tight grip on the
position you know black has this
weakness he's tied down to this weakness
and what's so
um impressive about this game is how Sam
you know held on to this grip on the
position the entire game
black never gets out black never gets
active
start to finish it's it's a really
really sad affair
so what can we do what can we do about
this A5 threat
any ideas
okay so some people in the chat have
have some good ideas
um so let's pass and let's just put A5
on the board
so here we we have two or three options
I guess basically we can allow black to
take on B4 and we would recapture we can
take on A5 or we can push past with B5
right these are the three options right
so the question is how can you make one
of those three options uh really
beneficial to you and I like what uh the
people in the chat came up with which is
the move Rook B1 or Rook B2 these moves
are pretty equivalent
um so after Rook to B1
A5 you know we're really never
interested in allowing black to open
this a file black is already on the a
file he's ready to open it up and we
just can't really challenge him there
but what we can do is sort of change
change the fight here and so with Rook
B1 we're actually activating along this
B file and we're going to try to make
that more relevant than whatever black
is doing
so here we have two options uh ba5 or B5
because again we're really not happy
with a takes B and in this case I think
both are are nice for white but one is a
bit better than the other so if we go B
takes A5
it's true that we're very very happy if
black takes back with the pawn because
then we did it we're active on the B
file our opponent is not active on the a
file but I think black might might try
something like Rook takes A5 here and
while we're getting active on the B file
he's getting active on the a file right
it's sort of this Mutual activity this
is still going to favor white but uh
black is at least playing for something
but with B5 here now this Pawn break is
actually going to be quite strong the
difference is now first of all we're
already supporting this pawn and now if
we take yes our opponent got rid of a
weakness on C6 but he's really just
transposed it to B6 now he's going to
have all the same problems except with
this Pawn on B6 and I think this Pawn is
actually actually going to die uh before
before too long here it's very very
difficult for for black to hold on to
this Pawn we are already ready to double
and we can even bring in another another
piece to help pressure
so that's Sam's move let's move Rook B1
and it's a very very strong idea so
that's you know how you you want to
start here you want to limit counter
play right we don't have immediate
breakthroughs you were right to look at
stuff like D5 and E5 and B5 all these
Pawn breaks but when you see that they
don't really work then you just you want
to prevent counter play so that's where
Rook B1 comes from very very nice move
now black plays uh Rook F to c8s
um actually missing missing his chance
to to find counter play just briefly I
want to mention this this opportunity
for black he could have tried this move
B5
and now after Rook to C5 he can still
come through with A5 he has prevented us
from playing our idea and now White's
gonna have to get pretty creative you
can try A4 and at the end of the
fireworks
um white is going to be winning upon
but black is is getting active so uh
black could have tried this sacrificing
a pawn to to get a ton of activity
um although it is very very difficult to
to prove that you're not going to be
just down upon here I think the lines go
something crazy like Knight to G6
threatening Knight F4 and then actually
something like Knight to E5 here like
it's it's it's crazy stuff you have to
be very very creative to survive with
black
um sorry so that that would be in the
case of of this move rather where now we
have this idea over to d8 so really
really crazy stuff
um that obviously wouldn't work in this
case because we tried this there's Rook
B2 so against this black would have to
find something else and it would just
get to get really crazy but yeah so
that's the only real way uh only chance
black had to not be significantly worse
in this game um and he's still a bit
worse uh but how to try this B5 idea so
interesting balance there
um black wanted to play A5 so white
played Rook to B1 threatening B5 in
response so black could have played B5
himself stopping our idea and insisting
upon A5 maybe this is the way he he
should have continued
instead though Rook after C8
and now our opponent really only has
these two ideas for how to uh how to get
active here so Sam keeps his grip on the
position and actually manages to make A5
and C5 sort of semi-permanently not not
a problem at all so what can we do to
challenge both of these ideas and sort
of make them uh make them a little bit
more irrelevant to the position
here we have some time black is not
immediately threatening to play either
move because again B5 is going to be
quite strong
so we have a couple moves here
to really tighten our grip
this B5 idea is nice it stops A5 and C5
for the short term
but we want something a little bit more
stable right it's a tactical solution
and we already saw that you know maybe
black has has some ideas
to uh
to insist upon A5
and as always we're looking for how to
improve all of our pieces at the same
time
okay any ideas before I give a hint
no okay so this night could be doing
more on F3 it's it's a pretty good piece
um because it's helping support our Pawn
on the semi-open file
uh but obviously E5 is is control G5 is
controlled H4 goes nowhere uh so we can
improve this Knight so there is a square
on the board that is pretty much ideal
for for this Knight right now and we can
get there pretty easily someone in the
chat is thinking about night ideas and
they were thinking about trying to head
for the D6 square but they did mention
that they thought it might be a little
bit slow
um and so yeah coming to D6 would be
nice but you know again black black
might actually challenge our Pawn in the
future
so there's a square on the board for
this Knight that's very stable it helps
us stop counter play down the D file
down the C file and down the a file
what's the magic square
anyone
B3 that's exactly right so if we put
this Knight on B3 you can just imagine
Rook d8 never a problem
A5 not a problem because again we're not
worried about A5 with the like you know
the pawn recapturing we're worried about
the Rook getting active
um after A5 and so that's not going to
happen for Knights on B3 same with C5
we're making C5 harder we're controlling
D4 controlling all the importance
problem squares where our opponent is is
aiming for counter play so
what's the move
Knight D2 it's exactly right
um our opponent comes up with Rook to d8
so insisting on not allowing us to do
these these more active things and now
simply Knight to B3
and as a pumpkin in in the chat says
um he was thinking it blocks our Rook
but actually it freezer like why does
our Rook want to be on B1 it doesn't it
wants to be somewhere like C1
threatening threatening down the C file
or maybe you know supporting a pawn
break somewhere else we want to liberate
The Rook so Knight D2 to B3 is very fast
it controls all the key squares
now black plays King to F7
and the time has finally come for us to
think about long-term plans we've
improved our night we've stopped all
active sources of counter play at least
for the moment it's going to take black
a while to come up with something else
so now we have more or less a free hand
so I love how Sam treated this position
he simply improves his position to the
absolute maximum before committing to
anything and in fact he was spending so
long to improve his position that his
opponent sort of broke into the pressure
and actually was the one to initiate
complications
so let's come up with ways to improve
our position it doesn't really matter
which one we we want to do first I just
want any any ideas that you have that
that makes our position better and then
we can decide between them
we have all the time in the world now
that we've stopped A5 and C5 our d-pawn
is well well defended
what can we do to improve our position
someone in the chat says King E3 that's
an easy one bring the king up support
our Center wonderful move
what else
okay you guys got this there's really
very few wrong answers here you have a
very very free hand
Rook b2c one beautiful move
um and then there's something else that
we can do sort of long term to uh
to make Black's life a bit more
difficult
there's one move we definitely want to
include and a longer term idea that we
want to kind of think about
right so F4 I wouldn't say we definitely
want to include this yet but long term
this kind of King Side Pawn storm is is
definitely going to be uh on the table
for us so ideas of f4 in a king Side
Pawn storm are going to be very
important
um but there's one move that we should
include for sure a structural move we
can change our structure just strictly
for the better here
yeah F4 is tempting but it is a move
that that you can't take back and it
might give our opponent much like how B4
allowed this A5 and C5 idea let me give
our opponent ideas of something like G5
someday trying to get get active play
so I don't know if that we want to
commit to F4 yet but it is a good idea
in the long run
so
black and many lines we were looking at
this Knight G6 idea or maybe you know G5
followed by Knight G6 and and jumping
into these kinds of squares so it's it's
a really simple move we would just want
to play the move G3 G3 the these These
are moves that we can definitely start
with see what kind of setup black is is
going to opt for and just kind of go
from there
um so people in the chat also say F3
yeah I think F3 is also a very good
improving move as well
um struggling to find a reason not not
to do this although you really should
say F3 or G3 doing both
um might might lead to some some kind of
counter play right you can imagine an F5
break and Knight F5 or something so I I
like G3 to start with and maybe you know
we'll leave this Pawn on F2 and decide
later on do we want F3 do we want F4 but
F3 not a bad idea either
don't think it would spoil anything at
least so let's see how Sam treated the
position he started with Rook B to C1
everybody likes this move black played
Rook to D7
and then he goes G3 so hasn't played
King E3 just yet but I think King E3
also would have been a fine way to to
start the position
black goes with Rook a it's d8
and now black plays or white plays Rook
to C3 really there's
no secret meaning behind this move it's
just uh maybe the rook's a little bit
more active on on C3 where it has a bit
a few more choices and then this is what
I meant by black uh sort of cracked
under the pressure and was the one to
break the tension or
um actually do try to do something
active first and this is
um a pretty good idea a lot of the time
when you have a nice grip on the
position is give your opponent some some
time maybe they'll try to do something
this is an idea that Ben Feingold talks
about a lot in in his lectures Sometimes
the best way to win is is to do nothing
and then your opponent gets so sad of
their their pathetic position that
they're going to try to do something
active and and do more harm to their
position than than good so that's the
case here narayana chooses to go with E5
trying to get active down down this D
file but of course this comes with a
pretty massive downside so what's the
downside to E5
um yeah that's one of one of the big
downsides there's also
um some something else some other
concession here
and we will see that those weaknesses
become very very relevant in this game
actually
so E5 gives whites
a good idea
you know we have one weakness in the
position and one weakness is pretty good
but oftentimes it's not enough to force
a win
and so another big problem with E5 some
people in the chatter are pointing out
it allows white to to kind of make
another weakness here and so D takes C
is going to be the way to go and now it
might not look like much but this epon
is actually isolated it's not the
easiest Pawn in the world to get access
to uh but it's isolated it's somewhat
weak and white might be able to use that
um to to his advantage
so we get D takes E5 and D takes E5
and now once again the question is how
do we improve our position
right things have have kind of changed
we put this Knight on B3 and this Knight
was great on B3 while it was defending
our weakness stopping A5 and C5 we've
got a Rooks on the C file or King on E2
so what can we do to improve with this
new change in structure whenever the
structure changes you really need to
reevaluate where all your pieces are is
this still where they belong or is
something different
so I sort of hinted maybe this Knight
doesn't belong here anymore you know
there's no Rook on A8 anymore
threatening A5 C5 is is miles away and
we're not defending upon on D4 anymore
and in fact we're never going to jump to
D4
so the big question is what can we do
with this guy now right B3 was a great
Square when we chose it but the
structure has changed so has
so has the optimal Square for this
Knight
and in this case actually there's
there's more than one square to think
about it's sort of a circuit of squares
that are really strong for this knife
okay Ahmed in the chat is a fan of
Julian's lectures and he says Knight A1
A1 Knight A1 always a good move but
maybe not here
there's a faster way to get to where
we're going
so what squares come to mind because
like I said there's more than one good
Square on the board here
right so
yeah D3 F3
C4 so I I like I like that idea we
definitely want to be targeting this E5
Pawn now how are we going to decide
between f3d3 and C4 actually one of
these squares is pretty significantly
better than than the other two
although we'll see that uh I think two
of them actually have
have quite a lot of Merit here
quite a lot of Merit
so just what does your intuition tell
you between these three which one sticks
out
okay
like that's why uh Knight A1 almost
makes sense to me it didn't take like
five minutes or something yeah and this
this is this is ambitious right
um
yeah I think that's an excellent idea I
think D3 is a pretty pretty decent
Square for this night but I do think
that
um it's it's pretty clearly second best
um so let's let's eliminate one which
one seems like the worst
okay maybe this is not such an easy
question after all
um so to me I'll go ahead and tell you
this one F3 seems like the worst of the
options
um it's very limiting to her pieces
actually and this Knight is doing
exactly one thing on on D on on F3 it's
attacking E5 it's not ever going to jump
to D4 it's not ever going to jump to G5
and again H4 is okay maybe there's some
Merit to trying to come to H4 but sort
of no man's land on the side of the
board
um D3 I think is a very nice Square for
the night because it does two things
it targets E5 and as long as this Knight
stands on D3 this Rook is not going to
get past this you know these obviously
we need to keep the Knight defended on
D3 but we're sort of shutting the door
on these Rooks shutting the door on a
lot of that activity for black it
actually does a third thing which is it
controls F4 which might become very very
relevant uh considering our idea of
potentially pushing through to F4 so D3
is a very nice Square for the Knight
because it just does a lot more than
this Knight on on F3 now that leaves the
square C4 why am I so enamored with the
C4 Square what's what is it about this
square that these other two squares
don't really allow for
I'll give you hints
it's because there's another destination
on this board that looks quite tempting
for for our night
and it goes along with the fact that we
have all this beautiful pressure down
the C file that's getting stopped by one
minor piece
so we can do something uh with the
Knight on C4 that kind of helps us
threaten to shake this blockade loose
and again we have a pretty nice grip on
the position so we we kind of have a lot
of time to think about it and figure it
out you know you were looking at like
the fastest paths for this night but I'm
not sure we even need to we have a lot
of time with this piece
yeah and uh bunzo in the chat has has
the idea here it allows us to take this
path right we can threaten to jump into
this F5 Square so like you said big
drawback to E5 gives up the F5 and D5
squares and in this case this F5 Square
we have such a good grip on it that's uh
93 to F5 it's going to be very very
challenging for for black to deal with
how does that help us on the C file well
if this Knight disappears the floodgates
are open we're coming through we're
breaking through we're winning this Pawn
getting active
so I still like your move Roku 1 to C2
and this is what Sam plays in the game
uh and actually maybe Sam played this
move before he had decided which path to
take but it allows both for Knight to D2
and Knight to C1
um
whichever path you so desire
so black plays Rook to D6 no reason not
to continue with the plan we go Knight
to D2 Rook to E6 Knight to C4 so black
in the meantime has sort of anticipated
our idea of targeting F6 or targeting
targeting E5 so he does this weird
little maneuver with the Rook obviously
it comes with the downside
the threats down the D file are are
pretty
non-threatening if there's only one Rook
there
so now we get this move Rook to D4
it's time to play
um that other improving move we talked
about now that the E4 Pawn being
attacked is actually relevant no reason
to not play G3 the old or F3 the only
reason we were a little bit hesitant is
if someday this G3 Pawn might get
attacked it's not looking so likely now
that E5 has been played so F3 just a
good good move
um now this King comes out to F6 over
protecting this Pawn nimzevich would be
happy
um and now Sam comes up with this move
Rook to D3 now is there any reason not
to play Knight to E3 here I don't think
so I think Knight to E3 is fine but Sam
realized that trading off one of these
Rooks might not be such a bad idea now
now why is that well our Rooks look nice
doubled up like this uh however uh they
are sort of Superfluous for for white
right they're serving one job attack the
pawn on C6 in the meantime black is sort
of cleverly placed his Rooks where
they're both doing something unique and
in situations like that it's not always
a bad idea to try to take one off the
board
um black played this move Knight to G6
anticipating a potential capture
allowing this Knight to step to this
awesome Square
and now white uh does continue with
Knight to E3
uh black bites the bullet decides it's
time to capture of course we were
thinking about coming to F5 especially
if we're to D6 we would now sidestep and
this threat is very very difficult to
stop in fact you might just be losing a
pawn
um so 93 takes takes check back 97.
um
okay
so now once again
we have a change in the position every
time the structure changes you should
reassess where your pieces belong every
time a piece gets traded you should also
reassess where your pieces belong
so let's think here where do our pieces
belong now that one set of Rooks has
been taken off the board
where to go next
so once again hopefully you guys have
heard of the the principle of two
weaknesses
one weakness here is is good but it's
not enough to break through right
Black's just defending it we need to
draw Black's attention elsewhere as well
we need to stretch his forces thin with
two weaknesses it can be very difficult
to to keep track of everything
okay
okay any ideas come to mind
difficult to attack right yeah
so Sam I think here
um another big reason why he traded off
the Rooks is he liked your your move
Knight D3
right Knight D3 inherently looks really
nice cards this Square this square and
again importantly
helps defend F4
however with two Rooks on the board we
it sort of ties down our pieces it gets
clumsy we need to have a rook also
defending our Knight as long as the
Rooks are doubled here and so I think
Sam wanted to get one set of Rooks off
the board so that he could very
comfortably put this Knight on D3 we're
defending it with the king is is always
going to be enough and our King is very
very well placed in the center so the
king will sort of always be there to
help the Knight
um and so that I think is another big
reason why Sam went for this Rook to D3
idea so let's let's start with that
let's get this Knight to that D3 Square
so Knight to C4 Rook D4 Knight B2
uh G6
King E3
work back to d8
and now uh black has played this G6 move
I'm not sure black needed to do this I
think this actually uh sort of advances
our plan uh a little bit faster
um so if black had left this this Pawn
on G7
just started passing for example I think
that nothing would have stopped us from
just continuing on like this
and then what do you think our big idea
should be once we uh once we arrive on
the D3 square like this
same had something very very nice in
mind
so while you guys are thinking dark
tiger in the chat um said seems like
Sam's plan jumped all over the place in
this game
um and the answer to that question is is
yes yes and no that's sort of the point
um his plan I believe was pretty much
always correct
at the time and chess you don't want to
get married to a plan because there are
a lot of things that that should
justifiably change your plan once again
those things are when the structure
changes or when pieces get traded so
every time the structure changed Sam
reassessed his plan reassessed where his
pieces belong and found the new correct
squares every time pieces got traded Sam
reassessed the position reassessed his
plan and and came up with the new best
plan so that's the key plans change in
chess whenever the structure changes and
the pieces get traded so yes his plan
jumped all over the place but but it
should have it was correct every time he
came up with the plan I think it was a
good one
okay
so what do you guys think in person
crowd
F4 is a great idea here so why did we
wait to play F4 until our night was on
D3 I've sort of been skirting around
this idea the point is we would
absolutely love if black captures our
double G pawns not so useful undouble G
pawns incredibly useful now we have a
past pawn and this is our second source
of active play that we needed in order
to really put the pressure on and in
fact even if this Pawn weren't so weak
these very fluid ponds are going to be
very very difficult for black to deal
with right we're pushing we're pushing
we're pushing and that's that's going to
be game so you might be saying well why
would black take and that's the the
other big benefit to this Knight on D3
with this added pressure to the E5
weakness we're really kind of coercing
black into capturing on F4 it's actually
in this position it's impossible to
defend E5 again without giving up C6 the
principle of two weaknesses can't hold
on to both
if black had tried a little bit harder
played something like Rook to D6 here I
think we could still very easily play
this move F4
and very sadly for black I pass
and what are you gonna do this move
seems risky
smooth also seems risky this move gives
a B5 these moves give up C6 this move
gives a P5 this move gives a B5 there's
just nothing to do here
um eventually you have to do this and
then you're busted
so hopefully that explains why black did
G6 is sort of desperation you don't
really want to go G6 here it makes more
weaknesses but uh but you know he he saw
the writing on the wall so King E3
black plays Rook to d8 sort of
anticipating some F4 stuff and now the
structure changed have Sam's plans
changed yet again what do you guys think
right so G6 of course weakens H6 and
maybe once again black is is having some
dream of playing H5 opening up a file
and getting active so Sam said yeah
don't even think about it Rook H2
um have fun defending that pawn now
Knight to G8 and now he's like okay
Knight G8 yeah now now I'm gonna go
Knight to D3
and under the pressure black again plays
plays G5 now
sort of at this point desperately hoping
to stop the idea of f4 but of course now
this changes the structure again and
once again uh Sam is going to change
plans so
what's the story now that G5 has been
played how does this change our ideas
yeah someone in the chat says zuzfong
even in the mid game yeah I mean I would
say this is a very late mid game
um sort of these queenless positions
often function as end games but uh these
zigsawang ideas
that's sort of what happens when you
have two weaknesses it can be very tough
to deal with both and your pieces are
going to start stepping on each other
when that kind of thing happens
so okay what does G5 change
compared to the pawn on G7 or even G6
yep F5 is open and H6 is weak G7 at
least defended the H6 Pawn in the in the
event of something on F5 here F5 open H6
week so of course what does that mean
for this Knight
time to start moving again right D3 was
the right choice was the right choice
but now the G5 is here D3 is no longer
the best Square so it's time to to get
on our horse again and and start jumping
around
um so Sam started with Rook to C2 which
is is fine and then King to E2 here
uh of course to get to F5 we're going to
need this Square for our Knight and Sam
just Begins the journey
uh and once again now nariana says uh
okay okay I I see what's happening and
uh play C5 but before it can happen to
him again if you play something like
Rook to D4
pretty sure Sam just had Knight to E3 in
mind and it's it's gonna get very sad
for you very very quickly you can try
something like Rook to D6 I guess
but I'll go Rook to C1
and once again there's just too much to
to keep track of here
um
this one I'm not sure I see a concrete
answer right away but uh it's sort of
it's sort of coming let's let's ask
let's ask how how do we win yeah okay
King to E6 and yeah it's time just now
to play Knight F5
um ah yes I I remember this one now I
remember this one
um so I think a lot of people
intuitively say my G pawns are doubled
why not play G takes but e takes is is
the clever idea here and this is the
reason why black is is just concretely
losing
um now
uh we have a path to Target E5 C6 is
weak H6 is weak and with all these
things together
um
you're not going to be able to hold on
to the position I think even immediately
this and
work H1
you can give me a check
but now
now you you can't do everything right
you just can't do everything here
okay maybe I should be more clever
Rook C4 for example
um eventually your your guys are gonna
fall
so
seeing that coming you know as these
strong players do nariana was like okay
I'll try C5 I'll at least change
something about the position before this
Knight F5 uh sort of death
Death Bell Tolls
so B takes C5 of course is the obvious
move we want to ensure this this Pawn on
the C file remains weak
black throws in Knight to C6
we move out of the way
now B takes C5 happens and the rest of
the game is is pretty concrete Sam says
I will take that C5 pawn and then win
the game so that's what he does
uh here black comes up with a fancy
little tactic don't think about taking
that guy causes you problems but Sam
just takes on A5 and with this extra
Pawn this end game is hopeless you can
try to defend passively
it's not going to help not gonna help
too weak my Rook is too active my king
is too active I'm gonna have a past Pawn
here on the E file Just Deadly black
Droid worked a B2 Sam said okay I'll
take your Pawn with check and check you
again and now I will push my passive
Pawn
and activate my king
and win the game
which you know the details of these air
gun games may be a little bit beyond the
scope of this lecture this one was more
about all these different plants uh that
that Sam came up with throughout the
game to tighten his grip on the position
make sure black never had a chance to
break free and beyond that slowly but
surely improved his position provoked
weaknesses improved his position
provoked weaknesses and then nariana
said okay I've seen enough I'm gonna try
C5 but just a a dead lost Rook end game
so that was a very dense game I didn't
expect it to take quite that long
actually but uh what what questions do
you guys have about this game did we
follow the the through line throughout
awesome any questions at all about it
okay well let's go through and do do a
quick review because again I think this
is the kind of the kind of game where
unless you're paying really close
attention it starts to look like these
Grand Masters are just moving semi
semi-randomly right you know you go
through okay we had this long opening
discussion
um about how uh White gets this
Advantage because black was a bit too uh
too urgent too Concrete in the opening
it allowed white to wait for black to
commit to putting these pieces here and
only then choosing Bishop F4
um Sam successfully turned this into a
concrete stable Advantage this nice move
G4 pressure down the C file is now the
story of the game over the next few
moves Sam ensures uh that his grip on
this position is very very tight goes B4
locking down the C Pawn after Rook to a
goes Rook B1 making sure A5 is no good
he finds this ideal Square for the
knights Bam Bam Bam no active play for
black at all
then improves this position
improves this position
now Narayanan says okay I've had enough
I'm going E5 trying to get active we get
a change in structure Sam reassesses
where do the pieces belong
he finds out C4 this is where I want to
be with my knight
I Rook D4 F3 King F6 or D3
and after the trade
he reassesses says okay now D3 that's
where my knight belongs
to D3
in Black seeing this coming plays G6 so
Sam throws in Rook H2 now bam we're on
D3 threatening to go F4
black tries G5 to stop us we reassess
where do our pieces belong bam now that
F5 is available back to C4 and Ariana
doesn't give us the chance to get there
go C5 first and now the game is just
very concrete Sam I'm sure it calculated
all of this
the weak Pawn take the weak Pawn Win the
winning Rook end game that's how you
beat a 2660. easy peasy uh you know
anyone could do it
uh but seriously really really
impressive game by by Sam shankland this
is the kind of game that that really
separates uh players at Sam's level from
players uh that that kind of get stuck
at this 20 2650 to 2670 level there
there's quite a lot of players there who
are just on the cusp of breaking through
to the 2700s playing with uh the best of
the best uh and it's games like this
that I think show show the separation
there Sam just understood everything at
every moment made the correct decisions
every time the position changed and
never let go
uh so hopefully you guys enjoyed this
game I know it took us a while to go
over but there was a lot to look at
um if you're here in person I believe we
have elshon coming online crowd you'll
have to wait we are recording elshon's
lecture but it will arrive at a future
date it's going to be a fun thing to
look forward to about Bobby Fischer so
thank you all so much for coming out my
name is Caleb dunby this has been the
road to 2000 and I will see you guys
next week
[Music]